these creations by international star
chefs at the chef's Days event in Berlin
are a feast for the eyes they are
prepared right in front of a live
audience and their creators explain the
ideas behind their recipes around 3,000
visitors showed up to the first edition
of the cooking symposium to learn from
these culinary masters
every recipe has a story I think the
next steps for every cuisine in the
world simply to want people to be in
touch with their senses Rasmus Colt from
Denmark is a master of New Nordic
cuisine his close to nature creations
have garnered three Michelin stars for
his restaurant geranium in Copenhagen
here in Berlin kovat shows how he
focuses on regional and seasonal
ingredients his dishes include roots and
blossoms he wants his guests to return
home from his restaurant not only well
nourished but also relaxed I think we've
seen a transformation in the fine dining
that you know it's a little more casual
but in the nice balance like what
everything needs to be balanced
otherwise I believe it's not working you
know if it's too formal in a restaurant
you don't feel comfortable and why will
you spend so much money and not being
comfortable you need to be able to relax
we live in a very hectic world all of us
with too many informations so that's the
timeout we have
Tim our a two-star chef from Berlin
offers those attending his master class
asian-inspired creations but the 20
visitors who tried out the food had to
book well in advance to get a seat at
his table today's dish is chinese-style
pork with watermelon this event also
gives an entertaining insight into how
was cooking philosophy he says
entertainment and a laid-back atmosphere
playing ever more important role in our
cuisine the top customer me and Big Talk
astronomy has been developing for years
it's no longer just about silver cutlery
chandeliers and having to wear a suit
and tie now it's more about having a
good time and entertaining people
entertain a historical brick hall in the
west of Berlin is the location for the
Berlin chef days guests can come here to
network and try out new products at a
special exhibition for example lemonade
made with basil
another new idea the greenhouse for your
apartment after the chef's days were a
great success in Graz Austria it was
time to expand Berlin is the German city
where so much is happening it's still a
place of new beginnings that suits the
chef's days perfectly we should be able
to experience new products new ideas and
Berlin is the perfect place for that but
in selphie hunters are in hot pursuit of
vladimir Mukhin the charismatic russian
star chef's restaurant white rabbit has
made it to number 23 on the list of the
world's best restaurants he's come to
Berlin to demonstrate the excellence of
fine russian cuisine creations made with
mussels caviar or dark rye bread that
are designed to trigger a taste
explosion I want to try the food and say
wow it's incredible you know it this is
for you can do it Wow okay you can do
something it's I I want to do Wow Danny
Garcia from our baya in southern Spain
is famed for his nitrogen tomatoes he
covers dishes with liquid nitrogen and
food coloring to look like tomatoes in
Berlin he presented a sweet variety with
raspberry meringue because the
andalusian is always looking for
inspiration he finds the chef's days
very interesting the event is a great
place for the star chefs to network and
here he can test his dishes on the
audience
[Music]
the best thing about this profession is
you meet people all over the world and
that introduces you to completely new
things from different cultures finally
Berlin star chef Tim hawa returns to the
main stage to explain his cooking
philosophy once again after the lecture
everyone gets a portion of Asian salad
over 1,000 portions in all two-star
croisine is for everyone a tasty way to
end a cooking symposium
you